hi I'm John Chesky and welcome to
comedians sell a house a show where we
have comedians compete to sell a home
why would we want to do that right
well comedians will do anything for
money and they lose confidence so they'd
be great at real estate right well let's
find out let's meet our first comedian
Andrew Santino what what do you want to
know it's my job I love it I've been
doing it for 13 years
it's great where does this even go why
are we like what is this healing for our
second comedian is fortune Teamster I
love stand-up and doing stand-up for 15
years
it's great way to connect with people
try to be positive make people laugh I
try to make their day better out of the
closet hey Dad I'm gay thank you guys
for being here John a fortune fortune
Andrew hey drew great to meet you thank
you all right you didn't know about this
surprise where is this fortune we're
gonna sell this house why would we you
said you wanted to buy a piece of I do
want to buy a piece of property
eventually but I thought that it would
be a cool thing for us learn how to sell
a house but the thing is it's been on
the market for a while even in beautiful
sunny Los Angeles California can you
believe it can you can ya I can't either
this is where we come in you guys the
challenge accepters yes are gonna come
in here and you're gonna rehab the
approach and you're gonna sell this
puppy mm-hmm that's right you stoked I
stoked but I don't want to do this you
scared that don't do that
not bad that's a very bad I'm not a
problem I are they filming it why are we
filming it because this is a challenging
challenge you're not hit you in the face
you have the most punchable head I've
ever seen in my so much hair very
positive do we get money for this we
don't get paid all right guys you ready
to do this let's go
right here guys we'll be going through
right this way sir I left something in
my car Jew Tom smack the thing away
you've been through the Attic
smack it
[Music]
[Applause]
connecting with people is the number one
way to master several things in life
the art of stand-up comedy making
friends in prison and getting people to
pull the trigger I'm buying a house okay
yeah you gotta connect yeah gotta
connect you guys get it you've got to
connect okay
well that's why we built you a cool
stand up stage right back there wait
what we're we're gonna do stand up
that's right so connect not even what we
did I'm done you can even finish this
thing you talking about it's totally
done look at you got your brick wall you
got the mic stand all you're missing is
the stool and we don't need one here
yeah I mean it's like it's kind of like
a Porky Pig exactly we're gonna call
this challenge five tight minutes in
front of complete surrenders the title
and the explanations you guys ready to
rock and roll wait no no no Deline I
think he was just going to go start
getting set up and getting ready to go
he's gonna go I wanna leave he's not
even my huh I don't want to stand up on
it that's what you do I don't that's
what you do for this class yes that's
what you wear to do it we're gonna do it
we're gonna connect we're gonna you
there stand up to sell this Wow that's
right and maybe you'll make a connection
with them that might come back later
when it comes time to close the deal and
they might listen to our podcast that's
right okay got a plug here we go all
right I'm not gonna do it
that enthusiasm is really gonna help
sell this house all right guys you have
seen her on HBO you've seen her on
Comedy Central please give a warm
welcome to fortune feed stock all right
you guys welcome how's it going
everybody's doing good yeah all right so
tired selling houses you know cuz real
estates a lot like marriage a lot of
contracts yeah and don't get me started
on dating guys are always comparing how
long their escrows are okay how about
this
knock-knock house how how's it going oh
I just got the light in stand up that
means you have to get off the stage but
in real estate that means you have
bought a great house with great lighting
I've never really done jokes about real
estate or houses before I think it went
pretty well people were laughing and I
got a few claps I mean a lot of those
people were probably just John but it
didn't matter I heard laughs and that
made me feel good well you've seen him
on Showtime you've seen him on Comedy
Central
please welcome to the stage mr. Andrew
Santino come on keep it going
yeah enough [ __ ] to kill you knock
them dead fine I didn't agree to this
you know what let me play you guys let
me play you guys some of my jokes from
my album you want to hear that yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't think the stand oh I didn't do
Stanley I'm not gonna do stand-up for
people at an open house I mean that's
can I be honest with you this is a
really bad time in my life like I'm
going through some emotional trauma at
home so I just like all this stuff is
really I've been you know this is just
not I'm not having fun my girlfriend is
leaving me that's the problem she's
gonna walk out on me she's packing up
she was blaring Adele when I got home
and was packing up her boxes so what'd
you guys think I thought it was fun yeah
I knew there big guy
he was fine yeah good time no I know a
good time but it was fine
fist bump you did a good job no oh thank
you I got you thank you I thank you guys
do we go home no I want to be done with
this well you are in a home right now
you know this is this is a
run-of-the-mill open house okay yeah so
homeowners will have these weeks
sometimes months in an attempt to sell
the house so we're out of stress
sometimes right yeah but not today
when I hit this button here it hit
Zillow offers they're gonna buy this
house from the owner let's just do it
and now it's your job to sell this house
guys everybody open house is over get
the [ __ ] out you put the pillow down
please mr. ego well that's a good turn
yeah I did get angry I lost my temper
and sometimes the dragon comes out and
it's not what I call it but that's what
my therapist calls it and you know not a
lot at the Quiznos in Simi Valley
anymore but that was me yesterday today
oh I'm here to win the day you know a
good miracle morning really resets me
don't want them here to buy this house
those people aren't gonna buy the house
why not oh they're professional open
houses I've seen them a 2030 other up
analysis they don't buy anything they
just come for the sugar cookies I I know
them I've seen them at 12 other open
houses there actually if there's mug
shots are on Zillow I don't know what
that means those are real people you
just talk to me like that well they're
not real people Andrew they're still
human beings they're not human beings
they're not even pre-approved I'm gonna
have to learn buddy now would that make
sense make a great progress though now
those people are losers let's do the
next challenge first impressions are
everything I can stand-up comedy your
opening bid set the tone for the entire
show right it's true yes well as a
realtor
first impressions are equally just as
important dare I say we call them a
brand yeah right and for example what
would you say my brand is Oh annoying
stepdad maybe let that soak in for a
minute
mm-hmm okay well thank you for that I've
learned a lot about myself well today
we're gonna be working on your brand and
you guys are in luck because I have a
huge surprise for you Oh what is it the
premiere leading American real estate
brand specialist and great friend of
mine is here for you today give it up
for muddled agape Oh
[Music]
hi my name is Ivana a peon and how are
you doing
that's called a soft moment and that's
just one of the things I do when I help
realtor's find their voice I'm gonna
teach you guys how to sell houses have
you guys sold houses before no yeah well
here's your problem you need to take it
up a notch on the style kay Funky's all
right what do I think about mano Manos a
lot
he's like a motorcycle it's like he's
got to let you know he's coming what
kind of motorcycle mano would be yeah
I'd have a sidecar for sure Wow Wow
it's here it is first day of the rest of
your damn lives I hope you're ready to
become somebody new behind this door
it's a bunch of clothes that you're
gonna wear a bunch of clothes for you
a bunch of accessories a bunch of stuff
that's going to make you the best you
you've ever been I'm not gonna tell you
what you wear no that would be too easy
I'm gonna discover what kind of an agent
you really are meant to become I focus
on all kinds of techniques holding onto
someone's hand until they say yes I will
buy this house and push squeezing some
people will say you're a criminal but
others will write you a check
you're not babies are you no good cuz
googoo gaga time is done
find your totem agent is a deep part of
your truth that I can't unlock for you I
wish I could but that's your journey
secure me please
let's all close our eyes imagine I want
you to imagine a sneeze in pure silence
a candle like inside of a piece of ice
or something children playing on earth
2092 an umbrella in a sea of candy ha ha
ha a squirt inside dryness open your
eyes a lot of thought going on yeah the
images that I placed before you all
embody who your true totem agent are
easy our is who your totem agents are ok
you said agent inside this bathroom is
the outfit that's going to define your
totem agent are you making for coming
your best self yes
become your best self oh my gosh oh my
gosh time is running out ok ok I'm gonna
get it I'm gonna get out of here thank
you so much I'll see you soon ok hope
not I was getting that too but I was
never here I was a ghost or something
the whole time ok ok maybe I was a fable
I'm not sure what the difference is but
I think I'm mythical
[Music]
fortune Fenster job how do you feel
about your outfit oh I feel great but
like a princess just look is it's
definitely more of a real estate look I
don't know that I want to wear Blazers
with wings on very often in life Andrew
Santino
don't say my legal name how do you feel
since your makeover I don't I didn't
make over any I'm the exact same that I
was when I showed up here it's the same
shirts I'm jealous
nothing changed you so you've got that
you've got designer jeans this is the
stuff I came in from my home homie I
want to go back to desperately do you
guys know where the say little home
actually starts in the hall and the nose
you think so wouldn't you mm-hmm it
actually starts at the bench for people
wait for the bus that you didn't know
that did you
now you do bus patrons buy houses all
the time that's why they ride the bus
because they don't invest in cars they
save that money for a down payment so
you might even find me - your first
buyer there so we're gonna just this is
true these are statistics they don't lie
we're the National Association of
Realtors they did a study it's a
National Association of Realtors yes
Andrew but don't worry about the
statistics right now yeah we gotta focus
on traffic we're gonna take your very
own oh yeah bus bench picture are you
guys ready to go to the studio and take
some pictures Oh gonna kill of cute guys
I've got a reveal for you turn around
the studio's right there let's take
pictures
I mean ah but you're not the judge of
these photos are you I'm not the judge
of these photos who is who
come on in Donny who's Donny
Donny's got decades of public
transportation under his belt he knows
all the makings of the perfect bus-bench
photo
take it away Johnny what's up Tommy so
first off what I like to do is kind of
look at a face before I start working on
it if you look at like all the negative
space in this area there's a lot more
here than this here like I could do some
tits right there right that make sense
and then at some point in time if
somebody else comes and they want to
augment you're not gonna add some poo
poo if I want it to oh it's a button now
it's a butt but then it's also it's also
tits then you know like I could do
double guns if I wanted to like that
[Music]
it's kind of like I go over een I'll
show like Wolverine dicks Wolverine
dicks yeah that's cool I'm really proud
of what I did
oh that's good I think the winner is
obvious to me oh yeah it is who is the
winner I'm gonna say it's Andrew oh okay
all right guys I'm up thanks Donny
thank you bye thank you so much John I
hope that you catch the bus all right
well guys after Donny's professional
assessment and all the penises it's
obvious it's pretty clear that the
winner is my new best friend Andrews not
your friend oh right on to the next
number one rule in real estate be a
trustworthy good fellow can't sell a
home to a dead person that's what my dad
always said
staging so important you guys it's not
just about putting the couch here
putting a vase over there it's about
creating me the essence of being at home
you want the buyer to come in here and
you want them to feel like they already
own the place oh yeah but also we got a
deal what's going on out there the
neighborhood
you gotta get the buyers to feel like
they're in their neighborhood are you
with me yes yes say it now staging
neighborhood stage a never I see a guy
who can make someone feel like they're
comfortable in their hood I see a
realtor right here I'm gonna take off
I'm gonna get out of here
I wish you could leave why do you have
my car keys saving you from yourself
let's get this house sold yeah don't do
that okay
I'm planning to stage the home in a way
where it really feels like I've lived
there because I'm basically gonna live
there I'm on a lease right now and it's
run up and I've been staying on friends
couches so I figured if there's a place
that's available I just I'm gonna crash
here for a minute
hello hello
cabbage get off the chair guilt cabbage
Jeff chair Hobbes sorry huh bad
oh it's just rest of my house I got a
little tired selling houses is tough
y'all okay well as you can see this is
our house let me tell you a little bit
about it we have a couch huh
looking great pretty nice couch yeah
okay well the biggest selling point of
the entire house let me tell ya
bookshelfs okay some people have to go
to Ikea they have to build it themselves
it takes five days please forget my
bingo set we had a pretty intense game
of bingo last night okay
b14 we'll play later we got a television
here for your pleasure you can't keep it
though fireplace this is a custom-made
fireplace we painted this brick white
nice and modern none of that that
regular brick color blue so boring what
is this the Brady Bunch house are you
guys hungry do you want anything to eat
water drink because that's part of an
open house sugar cookies where are they
Darrell do you know where the sugar
cookies are Darrell they do there is a
bong over there that might dictate where
the cookies are Darrell oh no that's not
there okay sorry sir the neighbors I
think my staging went awesome so people
came in they really saw it was like to
live there because I was living there it
was only for about two hours but it was
very effective my approach is just
selling the neighborhood is I just want
to glam it up a little bit you know some
people think that celebrities don't live
in North Hollywood but a little-known
fact they do who's that does anybody
want cookie does anybody want something
sweet to dip them in I don't want to be
here you remind me of some money you
don't have a redheaded brother
do ya similar vibe going on huh I think
that's big hit I mean the people going
through the house got a little quiet but
I'm assuming they were just sort of
processing how awesome this house is
I'll be back I actually paid for two lb
bags that's fine so what do you plan on
doing for the station I think that
they've screwed me over so much during
this day today that I'm gonna get him
back I'm gonna show home buyers what an
American family looks like
hi come on in
we're here for the open house yeah
that's why the door was open welcome you
guys have kids no we're we're planning
on it oh well stop planning can't have
him in this house previous owner put it
in the contract they said I don't want
little bambinos [ __ ] up this nice
beautiful house that they made so you're
thinking about kids better pull out my
friend kids can come over but they can't
sleepover why it's from the other other
owner it's a whole thing but it's not
good do you want to tell us about the
neighborhood why don't you go stand over
there on those two XS okay I'd like to
show you what it's like to live in a
house like this okay junior take your
backpack off the table right now mister
how did you know don't make me get your
father in here did I just hear a
backpack he's your mom's new dinner
table what do we say about that the
dinner table is just for eating and
family board game night exactly move on
before you miss the bus yes sir so what
time are you getting home same time like
always Oh or react I [ __ ] up Oh we're
we on a first-name basis now tell me you
do do you call that girl who I've seen
Oh goddamn it
I hired actors I want them to feel what
it's like to live in this home tell me
do you call that girl you've been seeing
around town with Maggie by her formal
title mrs. glory hole well if I didn't
come home to see the frigate of Africa
Andrew psycho Archer presents and vodka
I don't need to stick my dick to any
horse
Oh baby that's a typical American family
oh yeah what's going on here what the
fire that's so [ __ ] depressed right
now more about how you feel tell us how
you feel
oh my god have you guys done this to me
I can't believe that what does this make
you want to do I'm gonna kill you guys
I gonna kill you guys tell him how
you'll kill me I can't even explain
myself right now try what do you guys
what do you guys out that what what to
do to you what is it doing to you I'm
gonna break your balls first
mm-hmm I'm gonna suffer you both I can
hang your balls on the window I gonna
[ __ ] on your poor dead bodies you're
gonna [ __ ] anybody I mean Norman
Rockwell's couldn't have painted that
better the all-american family it's like
a headaches getting worse and worse like
they go from like just like pounding
bass to like voices something are they
talking to me that's like it's it's yeah
oh man is this challenge crazy or what
I'm loving these contestants they are
great it's so exciting
are you ready to get this show on the
road let's bring up your hosts you've
seen him on comedy central.com give it
up for the very hilarious number-one
comedian in the country John chefs key
[Music]
are there but it gives it a little bit
of texture it makes the room you know
you guys have been through some crazy
challenges right but you made it this
far are you excited
whoo good give yourself a pat on the
back it's been easy this far right just
cheesy yeah what's about to get a little
bit different now because the real
winner is gonna be decided by audience
oh how exciting
we've made it this far come on get on up
here
oh so nervous decide who our winner is
are you ready yes are you guys ready yes
mmm
couple of my dogs up here here we go
Andrew Santino get that you got some
fans huh fortune Finster hey thank you
thank you guys just to balance out let's
keep going Andrew Santino
yeah really getting in there yeah
fortune seems down he's such a good
sport and the winner is thank you the
pride of doing what you did wasn't that
exciting don't you feel great
alright guys open house is over get the
[ __ ] out go get out here go get out
scram
do you even sell a lot of houses oh yeah
oh well I'm hungry
Andrew come back put the cookie down get
out of here I had a blast
you did I want to buy this house to
spend the rest of my life with you
inside of it
sorry inside of you with it inside of
you okay I'm love with you hope I didn't
I'd love a house you don't love me I
love this house keep the house
well America there you have it
selling homemade so easy is it sometimes
you got to do a few things gotta brush
your teeth got to clean your car got to
follow directions I think you can do it
though all right
I'm John chef ski and this has been
comedians selling a house
[Music]
sometimes I'll see a house and I'll be
like dude I could kill myself there but
I snap out of it you know I mean there's
a lot of fun stuff to do and go north
Stern Drac find a new plaid
you